I live in Los Angeles and I've been
thinking of moving to New York lately
and whenever I tell my LA buddies that
they're like ooh how you gonna survive
the winters survive it's not the
revenant I'm not gonna be out in the
woods like I should have listened the
winters I'll step inside the apartment
turn the heater on no more winter I've
been looking for an apartment lately
it's an absolute nightmare
you know apartment hunting this is just
like online dating like you show up
excited right like alright you don't
look like your photo at all you're all
dirty and you got carpet
I think you should be able to test drive
an apartment before you move in you know
find out what kind of idiot you're gonna
live above could you never know like I
just lived five years below a 91 year
old man every morning at 5:00 a.m. he
would get up and ride an exercise bike
he's just up there Shh
[Music]
how long you need to live
you're 91 man
tap out if I was 91 I'd be riding the
real bike in traffic like hit me it's
gonna be weird to move to New York cuz
wheats not legal there yeah you know but
eventually it will get legalized just
like everywhere in America and I'm gonna
give you a tip if you've never smoked
weed and you think you're gonna jump in
the game now this ain't for you this
ain't beginner weed man you need to be
training for years to mess around with
this double black diamond stuff if
you're at home like we ought to try
marijuana go true no I hadn't smoked
weed in seven years you know a guy
walked up to me in Denver he goes hey
you want to get high and I go yeah let's
do it
I just took three hits he goes Oh
and then he just walks away I was like
hey what's up huh then and then I tried
to move right I was like oh I was
paralyzed my legs wouldn't work at all I
was drooling like a snake bit me I was
trying to get to my cars like this is
terrible who likes this then I got in
the backseat I was hiding for a couple
hours just freaking out paranoid right
and then I realized I don't even have a
car also if you've never smoked weed
when it was illegal you don't deserve to
smoke weed when it's legal you didn't
earn it if you've never smuggled up your
ass on a Southwest Airline flight or
through your stash out the window cuz
you're getting pulled over for expired
tags you know just jump in the game now
like thanks for going to prison so I can
smoke reefer for my anxiety I read
somewhere that weed smokers are less
likely to use condoms it's like yeah
course okay you know they forget
I feel like no one's using condoms you
know clap your hands have used condoms
no one full studio artists no one no
one's using condoms man my buddy called
me yesterday and he goes hey I met
someone online and I got lucky I got
used to condom right he goes man she was
cool that's what he said she was cool
what kind of STD test is that how does
that even go down what's the barometer
for cool like is it just about to happen
then he's like wait a minute you like
Radiohead she's like I love Radiohead
he's like raw dog thank you so much I'm
Dean down
[Applause]
you